this episode has been supported by lamda
dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here in an
earlier episode we covered a paper by
the name everybody dance now in this
stunning work we could take a video of a
professional dancer then record a video
of our own let's be diplomatic less
beautiful moves and then transfer the
dancers performance onto our own body in
the video we call this process motion
transfer now look at this new also
learning based technique that does
something similar where in goes a
description of a pose just one image of
a target person and on the other side
out comes the proper animation of this
character according to our prescribed
motions now before you think that it
means that we would need to draw and
animate stick figures to use this I will
stress that this is not the case there
are many techniques that perform pose
estimation where we just insert a photo
or even a video and it creates all these
stick figures for us that represent the
pose that people are taking in these
videos this means that we can even have
a video of someone dancing and just one
image of the target person and the rest
is history
insanity that is already amazing and
very convenient but this paper works
with a video to video problem
formulation which is a concept that is
more general than just generating
movement way more for instance we can
also specify the input video of us then
add one or at least a few images of the
target subject and we can make them
speak and behave using our gestures this
is already absolutely amazing however
the more creative minds out there are
already thinking that if we are thinking
about images it can be a painting as
well right
yes indeed we can make the Mona Lisa
speak with it as well
it can also take a labelled image this
is what you see here where the colored
and animated patches show the object
boundaries for different object classes
then we take an input photo of a street
scene and we get photorealistic footage
with all the cars buildings and
vegetation now make no mistake some of
these applications were possible before
many of which was showcased in previous
videos some of which you can see here
what is new and interesting here is that
we have just one architecture that can
handle many of these tasks beyond that
this architecture requires much less
data than previous techniques as it
often needs just one or at most a few
images of the target subject to do all
this magic the paper is ample in
comparison to these other methods for
instance the F ID measures the quality
and the diversity of the generated
output images and is subject to
minimization and you see that it is
miles beyond these previous works some
limitations also apply if the inputs
stray too far away from topics that the
neural networks were trained on we
shouldn't expect results of this quality
and we are also dependent on proper
inputs for the poses and segmentation
maps for it to work well the pace of
progress in machine learning research is
absolutely incredible and we are getting
very close to producing tools that can
be actively used to empower artists
working in the industry what a time to
be alive if you are a researcher or a
startup looking for cheap GPU compute to
run these algorithms check out lambda
GPU cloud I've talked about lambdas GPU
workstations in other videos and I'm
happy to tell you that they are offering
GPU cloud services as well the lambda
GPU cloud can train imagenet to 93%
accuracy for less than $19 lambdas web
based IDE lets you easily access your
instance right in your browser and
finally hold on to your papers because
the lambda GPU cloud costs less than
half of AWS and asia make sure to go to
lambda labs comm slash papers and sign
up for one of their amazing GPU
instances today our thanks to lambda
for helping us make better videos for
you thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I see you next time